on April 15th 20 19 firefighters charged
into the notatum Cathedral to call a
blazing fire
they took careful precautions while
spraying down the eight hundred fifty
year old Parisian monument like using
lower water pressure and avoiding
stained glass vulnerable to shattering
they also followed a plan to save
priceless relics and works of art in the
days following firefighters gave way to
a new team on the front line restoration
scientists from the laboratory for
historical monuments these researchers
were tasked with evaluating the
condition of the damaged stone mortar
and metal and guiding engineers on the
best way to restore the Cathedral even
as they try to reclaim what was lost the
lab researchers and others are also
analyzing samples of wood and stone for
clues to the cathedrals medieval past
their first order of business
stabilizing the Cathedral the lead roof
and the wooden Timbers that supported it
were mostly gone and there were holes in
the vaulted stone ceiling that
threatened a delicate balance of forces
between the vaults which push outward on
the cathedral walls and the flying
buttresses which provide an inward
stabilizing force in order to study the
structure temporary wood supports were
installed to prevent the buttresses from
toppling the walls to restore the
balance of forces researchers also need
to understand how the stone in the walls
and vault were altered by the fire
most of notre dam was constructed with
limestone and iconic stone used all over
Paris including at the Louvre at 800
degrees Celsius limestone can turn to a
soft white powder known as lime even
before this point at 300 degrees Celsius
fire can begin to reduce its strength
one way to estimate these changes is by
looking at the color of the stone beige
indicates a sturdy structure while a red
or black surface means the fire has
damaged its internal structure the high
porosity of limestone presents another
complication as firefighters hose down
the Cathedral some stones gained almost
a third of their weight in water
further changing the balance of forces
between the vaults and wall
the laboratory researchers are also
grappling with what happened to the lead
roof parts of it reached the melting
point of 300 degrees Celsius dripping
into the vaults and gutters but some of
the lead became airborne yellow smoke
billowed from the Cathedral as a result
the lead powder that settled after the
fire is toxic to humans making
researchers take careful precautions
when working in the Cathedral before
restoration even begins much of the
Cathedral must be decontaminated and the
mangled scaffolding put in place for
renovations prior to the fire must be
removed meanwhile the exposed interior
and fallen fragments of the Cathedral
have provided new opportunities for
research one researcher is using stone
samples collected from the Cathedral to
learn about the quarries they came from
other materials like the wood from the
Attic beams tell the climatic history of
the 12th and 13th century the long and
narrow shape of the beams also indicate
that these hundred-year-old trees were
grown alongside many other trees and
maybe we're even farmed with the
intention of using the wood to build the
Cathedral these finds provide glimpses
into the detailed construction of notre
dom it took a hundred eighty-two years
to complete
with signature pieces like the spire
added well after in the 19th century
centuries from now this fire will be
just another chapter in the story of
notre dom but the collaborative research
to understand its past and the careful
plans to reconstruct the cathedral will
allow future generations to continue to
be inspired by the iconic structure
[Music]